le premier tour des élections
municipales ce sera dans à peine plus
d'un mois le dépôt des candidatures en
préfecture les dépôts débute tout juste
et les candidats multiplient les
rencontres avec les électeurs merci de
nous rejoindre pour ce 7,8 politiques
spéciales municipal 2020 aujourd'hui je
reçois alexandra rosetti bonsoir vous
êtes c'est la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous briguer un
deuxième mandat
pour ce scrutin vous avez le soutien du
modem de l'ue dei de la république en
marche si je ne me trompe pas mais pour
autant est-ce que vous revendiquez tout
d'abord ces étiquettes politiques ou
est-ce que votre liste et plus ouverte
que cela alors heureusement elle est
beaucoup plus ouverte que cela moi je
suis dei depuis nombreuses années
maintenant
moi je souhaite comme ça a été le cas en
2014 une liste à partisane c'est à dire
qu'on fait forcément de la politique
quand on est dans une commune
mais pour moi ce qui est important c'est
le projet comporte et les valeurs qu'on
peut avoir en commun donc voilà
l'essentiel c'est que nous soyons tous
en phase sur l'avenir de voisins lors du
scrutin la dernière fois il y avait déjà
plusieurs listes de plus ou moins même
sensibilité politique c'est encore le
cas cette année avec un autre opposant
il vit à fond d'eau qui s'est allié à
tirer gastaud vous regrettez que votre
famille politique au sens large
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord
je pense que ça dépasse la question des
clivages politiques
c'est une façon de concevoir les choses
c'est une façon de concevoir la ville et
je pense qu'on n'est pas du tout en
phase sur sur ces points qui sont à mon
sens capitaux dont j'ai envie de dire
les partis politiques n'ont pas beaucoup
à faire dans ces histoires là vous êtes
élu depuis 2001 vous étiez adjointe au
maire auparavant vous êtes donc mer
depuis 2015 puisqu'il ya eu de nouvelles
élections après 2014 suite à un recours
pourquoi vous présentez une
nouvelle fois quels sont les projets que
vous allez mener on va en parler mais
qu'est ce qui vous a motivée en tout cas
en fait en un mandat de maire puisque
avant comme vous l'avez dit j'étais
adjointe mais donc c'est pas moi qui
forcément clottey tous les projets en un
mandat on a quand même peu de temps pour
mettre en place ce qu'on a envie de les
projets qu'on a envie de porter donc on
a démarré un certain nombre de choses et
c'est vrai que naturellement on a envie
d'aller un petit peu et poursuivre
d'aller au bout et puis c'était aussi un
mandat d'une vraie prise de conscience
de tous les enjeux qui pour les
différentes villes les enjeux par
exemple de terre de transition
énergétique donc on a fait des choses
mais on se rend compte qu'il ya encore
tellement à faire que évidemment ça
donne envie de poursuivre cette
dynamique avec une équipe aussi qui
apporte encore une fois c'était mon
slogan 2014 un nouveau regard et bien
c'est pareil
une partie de l'équipe la moitié à peu
près qui est renouvelée et qui va aussi
nous re bousculer sur nos façons de voir
les choses
donc j'en veux dire la vie la vie
municipale c'est toujours en mouvement
et il y aurait un goût de la
satisfaction de ne pas aller au bout de
certains beaux projets que nous avons
lancée sur le bilan justement que vous
faites de votre mandat vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir accompli et rempli
tous les objectifs que vous étiez fixés
oui alors au surtout au vu des obstacles
que j'ai pu rencontrer pendant pendant
ce mandat
c'était un gros travail de
réorganisation des services de la ville
de façon à pouvoir répondre justement à
nos priorités et c'est vrai que je suis
assez assez fier de ceux de ce bilan
bien sûr il reste des choses à faire
évidemment il ya des sujets importants à
voisins qui n'ont pas encore pu être
terminée mais je pense que nous avons
fait beaucoup pour améliorer le cadre de
vie
nous avons fait beaucoup également pour
accueillir les nouveaux habitants qui
sont arrivées pour nous occuper de 2
de chacun de nos habitants quelles que
soient leur âge voilà donc on a on a eu
à coeur d' impulser une politique
dynamique et c'est ça qu'on veut
poursuivre il reste tout de même un
point noir c'est le transport la
circulation sur votre commune vous aviez
évoqué le contour de monde voisins par
le sud notamment ça ne s'est pas fait si
vous êtes élu une nouvelle fois qu'est
ce qui pourra changer
qu'est ce que vous pourrez faire sur
cette question de la circulation qui a
tendu quand la population alors la
circulation il n'y a pas qu'à voisins
bretons n'ont évidemment que ça ça pose
problème je pense que tous les maires
des communes autour en serons d'accord
nous avons essayé des choses nous avons
fait une expérimentation en particulier
alors qui a été un petit peu ralliée par
mon opposition mais si on ne fait rien
effectivement on peut pas avancer donc
cette expérimentation nous a permis de
bien identifier les différents points
sur lesquels il faut absolument agir les
différents leviers sur lesquels il faut
agir nous avons porté ce projet de
contournement et je reste convaincu même
si les freins sont telles que je sais
très bien que ça ne pourra hélas pas ce
faire quand vous parlez de frein les
freins ce sont des freins bas d'abord
environnement tout cela ça me semble
faux passés dans une forêt donc ça c'est
effectivement pas neutre donc il
faudrait pour ne pas l'abîmer peut-être
passé en aérien ou en souterrain ce sont
des coûts qui sont absolument
prohibitifs et puis également le frein
de mon collègue mer par exemple de
manille qui lui est fermement opposé à
cette solution
donc je vais pas imposer un autre maire
ça pas possible de toute façon ce qu'il
ne veut pas donc il faut je continue à
chercher de solutions des solutions qui
soit tenable c'est à dire que moi mais
opposant propose des mini tunnels bon
c'est très bien sauf que c'est intenable
techniquement et insoutenable
financièrement ça je pourrais le
démontrer sans aucun problème donc on
peut tous se remettre sur la table mais
je pense qu'il faut aussi être
raisonnable de façon à ne pas faire de
promesses qu'on ne pourra pas tenir des
solutions il ya des solutions
il ya des solutions forcément il faut
chez nous en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne voisin il ya des solutions qui
vont même jusqu'à guyancourt puisqu'il
faut le traiter plusieurs carrefours et
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied avec
saint quentin en yvelines parce que
c'est leur compétence et avec le
département puisque ce sont des
départementales pour justement continuer
à chercher des solutions mais tout ça ne
peut pas se régler que au niveau de
voisins-le-bretonneux et avec les maires
du canton de maurepas nous avons déjà
initié une conférence des mobilités avec
tous les partenaires
nous sommes allés au delà de 50 ans nous
sommes à l'ère versailles grand parc
jusqu'à paris saclay justement pour
regarder ensemble quelles solutions pour
un maître ne vient à les transports en
commun il ya là il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à pousser mais tout ça prend
un petit peu de temps évidemment vous
avez évoqué les critiques de votre
position votre position qui s'est montré
critique également sur les questions
d'urbanisme question de construction
aujourd'hui il faut poursuivre cette
c'est ce développement des constructions
sur voisins-le-bretonneux c'est
nécessaire sachant que voisins le
bretonneux n'a perdu que des habitants
ces dernières années ou est ce qu'il
faut au contraire maîtrisé sur le
prochain mandat
alors maîtrisé c'est ce que je fais
depuis le début c'est à dire que nous ne
pouvons pas un ne pouvons pas interdire
les constructions
par exemple un propriétaire privé qui
vend son terrain le maire ne peut
absolument pas lui refuser son permis de
construire
s'il rentre dans les règles du plan
local d'urbanisme et puis nous avons
aussi la pression de l'état qui est très
forte
qu'est-ce que voisin est une ville
déficitaires en logements sociaux donc
tant que nous n'aurons pas atteindre 20
5 % de toute façon l'état ne nous
lâchera pas vous êtes à combien
aujourd'hui sur 18 et nie donc tout
l'art tout ce qu'on a pu mettre en place
là ce sont des règles d'urbanisme qui
aujourd'hui on doit le voter le 25
février d'ailleurs nous avons une
révision du plan local d'urbanisme nous
nous restreignons la constructibilité en
centre ville
mais il faut en fait c'est une
contrainte qu'on nous impose
eh bien nous nous voulons faire une
opportunité une opportunité d'accueillir
les habitants dont nous avons besoin
parce que une ville qui vit une ville
qui perd des enfants à l'école et des
classes qui ferment tous les ans une
ville du père des habitants c'est une
ville qui perd de son attractivité et
qui se retrouve avec un nombre
d'équipements publics
à porter avec un non plus réduit
d'habitants donc faisons en sorte que ça
accueille de jeunes familles de jeunes
couples de façon à ce que notre ville
garde son dynamisme
j'ai pas compris moi ce qu'ils voulaient
faire en terme d'urbanisme très
honnêtement
parce que dire aujourd'hui on arrête
tout c'est pas honnête
donc il faut il faut dire nous
maîtrisons nous maîtrisons en demandant
plus des espaces verts dans les
programmes nous maîtrisons en réduisant
les auteurs nous maîtrisons en
protégeant des maisons c'est ce que nous
faisons dans nos prévisions actuelles
quand je suis arrivé j'ai refusé des
permis j'ai rendu des zones
inconstructibles en particulier par
sombre dans la zone du lac
il y avait un beau projet ou donc je
n'ai fait que ça maîtrisé mais il faut
maîtriser mais on est obligé de répondre
à nos obligations donc essayons de faire
de cette contrainte une opportunité pour
nous d'un impression très rapidement
vous aurez l'occasion d'évoquer votre
programme lors d'un débat qu'ils
organiseront prochainement sur notre
antenne ce sera le samedi 22 février à
17h pour le direct et bien sûr aussitôt
consultable sur notre site internet
débat diffusé aussi sur radio sensations
juste un mot sur vos différents axes de
programmer sur un point en particulier
le développement durable parce que vous
souhaitez mettre l'accent dessus
oui bah je pense que y'a pas un selmer
maintenant qui peut faire un programme
où il nous parle pas de développement
durable alors non seulement d'un point
de vue transition écologique évidemment
il nous avons ce magnifique projet
d'écoquartier de la remise qui commence
à démarrer et qui va avoir beaucoup de
qualités
environnementale et ça ça doit être
déclinée au niveau de la ville et puis
le développement durable c'est aussi
s'occuper de la santé des gens de nos
personnes âgées du handicap
et puis aussi avoir peut-être société un
peu plus fraternelle et d'entre aide
dans notre commune merci alexandra
rosetti candidat donc pour un deuxième
mandat de maire à voisins le bretonneux
je rappelle que deux autres listes se
présentent sur cette commune merci à
vous merci beaucoup
nous partons pour elle on court à
présent ou trois listes s'affrontent
cette année du côté de michel rossi pour
la liste est longue course et vous les
propositions commencent à être dévoilés
reportage marylène iapichino elle a
lancé sa campagne fin janvier michel
rossi investi par le parti présidentiel
mène une liste citoyenne un premier
engagement politique pour cette jeune
retraitée qui s'investissent est déjà
dans sa ville dans le tissu associatif
notre liste comporte des personnes
issues du ps des radicaux de gauche du
centre des sans étiquette et des proches
de valérie pécresse redynamiser la ville
réveiller la démocratie locale et
préserver valoriser le cadre de vie sont
les trois grands axes du programme de
elancourt c'est vous c'est de relancer
ces comités de quartier on aimerait
avoir des référents dans ces quartiers
pour avoir des échanges réguliers avec
eux connaître leurs préoccupations leurs
parler nos projets pour que ce conseil
municipal l'a aussi reflète l'avis de
ces quartiers un programme pour
réveiller une ville qu'ils considèrent
aujourd'hui endormi fruit d'un travail
dé change avec les habitants comme lors
de cette réunion publique qui se termine
en trois tables rondes sur les
principales thématiques
je pense qu'au bout de 24 années une
équipe municipale tombe automatiquement
dans une certaine routine s'éloigne de
la
des soucis quotidiens des élans courtois
quand j'ai rencontré effectivement
michel rossi j'ai vu quelqu'un va
appliquer à
faire travailler les gens ensemble à
bien comprendre la proche globale des
différentes problématiques qu'elles
soient économiques écologiques et du
casio la liste continue d'aller à la
rencontre des habitants en faisant du
porte à porte et du tractage trois
tables rondes auront lieu pour continuer
d'affiner le programme
prochaine date le 24 février sur les
thèmes du sport de la culture et des
écoles deux autres listes sont déclarés
à elancourt et vous pouvez revoir le
débat entre les listes déclarées les
têtes de liste des déclaré sur la ville
d'elancourt sur notre site internet il
souhaitait uniquement interpeller les
candidats pendant la campagne déçus de
leur proposition il a décidé de se
lancer à lui-même cette année
coursegoules gorgo la barre dont
présente ses premières propositions à
villepreux cours aux golgoht la ville
provient depuis 20 ans tête de liste ou
simplement villes pro se lance en
politique il a mené sa réunion publique
vendredi 7 février
les candidats me paraissent pas à la
hauteur les programmes qu'ils présentent
ils sont floues et sont pas très claires
et la vide à moi mon sens méritait autre
chose mérite une transformation la ville
2003 devient une ville dortoir et un
abandon de la culture le candidat de 53
ans ou être réanimé la ville et le
théâtre fermé mais aussi créer un musée
pour la ville ou encore l'aménagement de
l'ale de l'école jacques gillet en une
grande école de musique l'éducation un
point important pour ce candidat il faut
se structurer
élargir construire agrandir notre
collège il faut que la ville rayonne un
rayonnement qui pourrait être celui
d'une pièce kouros golgoht l'abe
souhaite instaurer une monnaie locale
il mesure phare que je dirais pour les
commerces ou de soutenir la création
d'une monnaie locale à villepreux je
pense que l'exemple dans les yvelines
n'existe par mais en france ça très bien
manque marché le candidat souhaite une
augmentation des effectifs de la police
municipale
parmi les autres projets étudiés 1 est
la priorité de ce candidat qui est aussi
médecin chirurgien spécialiste en orl la
santé il faut faire à mon avis hein
c'est pas mon avis c'est le projet une
maison de garde qui serait ouverte 7
jours sur 7 de 8h30 à amy lui elle la
prochaine réunion publique de cours aux
golgoht lab est prévue le 22 février
avant de refermer cette émission un
dernier mot concernant trappe ou une
quatrième liste entre en jeu celle de
said jalili baptisé citoyen en action
elle regroupe des habitants de la
commune sans expérience en politique et
ils entendent ramener les
abstentionnistes aux urnes ils étaient
près de 55 % en 2014 dans cette ville
c'est la fin du set 8 politique on se
retrouve mardi prochain en direct à
18h45
[Musique]